Анна Василівна. Мені цілих сім місяців!
Давай, доця, мама тебе візьме! Опа! Ходи до мами! Ой, як тобі все цікаво!
Мар’яна Мамонова - нині щаслива мама маленької Ані.
Твій дружок! Так! Тю-тю-тю-тю!
Жінка цінує кожну прогулянку з донькою.
І кожен день тут - у рідному Львові.
Бо знає, що її дитини могло б і не бути поруч,
а сама вона ще не так давно щодня відчувала себе у небезпеці за крок до смерті - у російському полоні.
Там їй судилося провести майже пів року. Вагітною.
Ця дитина дуже багато пережила!
Слава Богу, що вона нічого не бачила.
Але емоційно вона багато пережила.
24 лютого 2022 року Мар’яна Мамонова несла службу як начальниця медслужби батальйону ЗСУ в Маріуполі.
Там вона з побратимами і посестрами довгий час надавала допомогу пораненим у підвалах "Азовсталі".
У березні, коли росіяни щодня вкривали місто обстрілами, Мар’яна дізналася, що в неї буде дитина.
Земля з-під ніг пішла. Не пішла, а просто вискочила! Для мене це був шок.
Ані чоловікові, ані батькам, ані у своєму батальйоні Мар’яна не зізнавалася про вагітність,
бо знала, що евакуюватися з Маріуполя їй вже не вдасться і допомогти їй буде нікому.
Шансів виїхати не було: зелені коридори прострілювалися.
І були вже оці фільтраційні пункти.
Все одно б дізналися, що я військова.
Я прийняла рішення, що я буду з хлопцями до кінця.
Попри тяжку ситуацію на фронті і свій стан Мар’яна тривалий час продовжувала евакуювати поранених.
Втім, 4 квітня, рано зранку, командир попросив її та інших побратимів і посестер вийти з "Азовсталі".
Без пояснень, для чого.
Ніхто не міг подумати, що ми їдемо здаватися в полон чи нас візьмуть в полон, такого зовсім не було!
Стоять військові, зі зброєю, з собаками, які говорять, що повільно потрібно встати і підняти руки догори.
Здається, що це все якась зйомка якогось фільму, і зараз все це зупиниться!
Для жінки здатися в полон було найстрашніше,
бо дуже багато летальних випадків і знущань,
було дуже багато випадків саме з маріупольськими жінками зі сторони Російської федерації.
Мар’яну та інших побратимів і посестер взяли в полон та відвезли до колонії "Оленівка" в окупованому Донецьку.
Там їй лише раз дали подзвонити чоловікові.
Тоді він і родина жінки довідалися, що вона очікує дитину - в полоні ворога.
А далі тривали довгі допити, недоїдання, недосипання і задуха в тісній камері.
На пізніших термінах вагітності жінка не могла робити фізичну роботу в колонії, за яку ув’язненим давали їжу.
Тож, харчі їй діставали інші жінки з камери.
Та найгірше, каже, був не голод, а приниження з боку росіян.
До мене ставилися з якимось таким презирством.
Тобто: "Ну от, доки всі воювали, чим ти займалася в бункері, раз ти вагітна?".
Я була бандерівка, з Західної України, "бандерів треба убивати", "народиш маленьку бандерівку чи бандерівця".
Та найстрашніша мить життя Мар’яни була попереду,
коли росіяни погрожували їй відібрати єдине, що вона тоді мала з собою - її дитя.
Мене допитували години чотири.
І один з військових сказав, що якщо я не скажу те, що йому потрібно, він поклопоче,
щоб мене забрали в Росію в одну з виправних жіночих колоній, де жінки відбувають термін.
Де я народжу, і мою дитину заберуть в один із дитячих будинків Росії.
І російська влада краще виховає дитину, ніж мама-вбивця.
Бо на початку мене звинувачували у вбивстві маріупольських дітей.
Минуло кілька місяців, кожен обмін полоненими по кілька разів зривали самі ж окупанти.
Вийти з "Оленівки" до пологів для Мар’яни ставало усе менш реалістичним.
А умови - були дедалі гірші.
Ви знаєте, був один раз, коли мене закрили в клітці і вивели на прогулянку.
І один з конвоїрів їв яблуко. Я так їсти хотіла. Настільки хотілося їсти!
І він їв це велике червоне соковите яблуко! І він знав, і робив це при мені.
Як звичайне яблуко може зробити щасливим після пережитого в руках загарбників, знає він.
4 лютого 2023 року Україна і весь світ назавжди запам’ятали схудлого, напівсивого чоловіка,
який із трепетом тримає яблуко в руках.
Це був Максим Колесніков, який вперше ступив на рідну землю після звільнення з полону.
Вперше за рік їм свіжий фрукт! Страшно! - Смачного! - Офігенно!
З яблуком вийшло кумедно доволі.
Я був дуже щасливий, тому що я повернувся!
Ви не уявляєте, що це таке!
Полон не лише фізичний, а і моральний - це головна тактика російських загарбників.
Про це каже Максим, який після пережитого у лещатах ворога досі відновлюється.
Він потрапив у полон під час оборони Київщини поблизу Макарова у перші тижні повномасштабного вторгнення.
Здатися росіянам - для Максима було чимось нереальним, бо він вважав, що взагалі не виживе у тяжкому бою.
Три дні вони нас дуже жорстко крили вогнем.
Ми на собі відчули все: і "Гради", і міномети, і обстріли з танку.
Коли було зрозуміло, що у нас геть немає нічого протитанкового,
у нас є великі втрати в людях, і танки просто катаються і впритул розстрілюють людей,
командир частини прийняв рішення, що частина людей здається в полон.
Максим здався в полон, коли в нього і побратимів скінчилися всі боєприпаси.
Каже, спершу з ними російські військові поводилися нейтрально, годували і не застосовували силу.
Багато хто підходив до нас і казали: "Зачем вы так? Что вы на нас вот это вот полезли?"
Та наступного дня приїхав загін кадирівців.
Ті швидко закували полонених кайданками, відлупцювали і повезли до кордону.
До Білорусі привезли і українських військових, і викрадених цивільних.
Уже на місці усіх почали допитувати, каже Максим.
ФСБ-шники були доволі цікаві.
Питав мене, як там з російськомовними.
Я кажу: "Ну, нормально, проблем не було".
А він мені каже: "Ну сейчас-то вы чего боитесь правду сказать?"
Від мене все намагалися добитися, що це у нас нацизм.
Ну я косив дурня, я казав, що я не знаю, що таке нацизм.
Потім вони ще у полковника взяли інтерв’ю, він був більше різкий:
і коли нас повернули в приміщення, вирішили, що достатньо, нацистів нема,
ось полковника цього достатньо жорстоко побили вони.
Після цього на Максима чекали довгі місяці у російській колонії в Брянській області.
Ціль росіян, каже чоловік, зламати кожного і кожну в полоні, аби ті дали потрібні свідчення.
Далі фільтрація так званих "нацистів" на знищення,
інших - на нелюдські умови існування в колонії,
і потім, якщо ті виживуть - на обмін.
Максим потрапив до тих, хто лишався і чекав, що одного дня пекло скінчиться.
Ну, вони просто методично били кожного.
У них така була…Беземоційно, просто шикували і дубинками всіх…
Трошки приходили вже такі заведені: "А! Фашисти! Нацисти!" Мені по печінці прийшлося…
Я потім місяця два не міг спати на боці, бо в мене боліли всі ребра.
Були цивільні. Над ними жорстко знущалися, травили собаками, були покусані.
У колонії Максима та його співкамерників на сніданок годували шматочком хліба з водою,
і щоранку змушували співати російський гімн.
А ще - іноді їм вмикали російське телебачення.
Там бувала в них така рубрика "Наші герої", що один їх якийсь чувак знищив 10 танків.
І ми такі: "Боже, пфффф! Що ти…Що ви несете?"
І 20 вересня останній раз, як у нас був телевізор, ми дізналися, що з Харківщини їх поперли!
Після цього новин і доступу до зовнішнього світу полоненим не давали.
З кожним місяцем Максим усе більше худнув - загалом втратив 16 кілограмів.
Але чоловік був упевнений: його обміняють, і він повернеться додому.
Нас визнали, що ми підемо на обмін, це означало, що ми не "нацисти",
і нас обміняють, а не будуть намагатися натягнути якусь карну справу.
Я вважаю, тому обміни і почалися.
Це було 31 січня, і тут зненацька відкриваються двері камери.
Називають прізвище мого товариша, а потім другого мене.
"Собрали вещи и на выход". Ааа, фух! Звісно, дуже велика надія!
Переїжджаємо кордон, оця зона безпеки, і одразу як зупинились - це повне відчуття дому!
Зараз - за три місяці після звільнення - Максим вже знову на службі в ЗСУ.
Втім, його реабілітація ще досі триває..
Каже, моральні наслідки полону досі з ним, але він налаштував себе з самого початку - вистояти.
Я тоді ставив собі завдання, що мені треба зберегти себе, свою особистість.
Полон - він не назавжди! Ми - такий собі знак надії, що люди повернуться.
Про те, що справжня віра в повернення додому дає змогу вижити, каже і Мар’яна.
В полоні на дев’ятому місяці вагітності вона в страху чекала пологів,
після яких у неї назавжди заберуть її маля у Росію.
Але диво сталося: одного дня по неї прийшли і відвезли на літак - додому.
Я постійно питала: "Куди ми їдемо?"
І коли нас посадили в літак, оця людина, яка займалася обміном, сказала:
"Мар’яша, ти їдеш додому. І народжувати будеш вдома".
Навіть якщо я буду народжувати, ми нікому не скажемо,
бо ще мене десь по дорозі висадять!
21 вересня нас поміняли! Відкриваються двері швидкої допомоги, мене беруть за руки…
Відкриваю очі: "Вітаємо в Україні!"
21 вересня - день обміну - Мар’яна вважає своїм другим днем народження.
За чотири дні після цього вона народила здорову дівчинку - Аню.
Полон - це не кінець. Я б сказала, що полон це переломний період в жінки, яка це пережила.
Полон дав кожній жінці, яка пережила його, зрозуміти, що вона може багато чого!
Що вона сильна! Вона залишилася жива!
Про історію Мар’яни Мамонової Фонд ООН у галузі народонаселення зняв документальний фільм.
Де вона - жінка, що пережила російський полон з дитиною під серцем.
І знала, що саме ця дитина дасть їй сил усе витримати.